[Musique]
je suis noir grand je suis noir art à
lucas lui neg mawon je suis en parlera
de nery sall
françois lamarche seine initiative 2
dans lequel marche
interview c'est un conseiller qui sont
pas ils sont pas trop sa frappe
ils sont pas du saloon et non pas une
bonne ambiance voilà j'ai fait à une
marche moi de mon côté avec les indiens
des imams des imams qui soutiennent non
non non c'est pas ça tu sais très bien
les umc peu good vibes pour coup il a
pas tord sais pas c'est pas super
ambiance soutien j'habite à mon
anniversaire 5 imams on va pas mettre
une ambiance de financer bas en terme
d'ambiance je prends de l'afrique sont
bardées montreuil c'est en ce que tu
fais avec tes fesses des grosses fesses
c'est un peu tout cela allait peut-être
tort qu'ils sortent la terre natale est
rentrée elle même peu de conscience même
peu de faux mais un peu de maturité
c'est tout ça va c'est pas le rappeur
préféré des collégiens qui doit me
donner des leçons drap tendu des films
de kung fu chi sel il a pas tord n'ai
pas peur
c'est d'une connerie
[Musique]
ah ah